let's take a look and listen
three ways to let your friends know what
gender you're feeling today gender fluid
edition
peter said that you don't have to do any
of these these are just things i do one
pronoun bracelets you can get different
colored bracelets with different
pronouns on for example this one says
this one says he him and this one says
they them the colors also correspond to
how i'm feeling so black usually goes
with my black male outfit um this
usually goes with like my pink
female outfits and this usually goes in
my non-binary outfit just a way to let
your friends know what gender you're
feeling today and how they can address
it pins are also another good option for
example i have this one that says they
them for anything non-binary two
clothing
personally i present very typically
masculine when i'm feeling um like a guy
and i present more ambiguously when i'm
feeling like a non-binary and when i'm
feeling like a girl i usually wear those
a pink anyone can wear and be honest
does this sound healthy to you
and she's this is obviously a female
okay i'm gonna say it this is a woman
young young woman this looks like a
little girl to me i don't know what her
age is my guess would be late teens 18
19 is my guess
you think she's no i think she's got to
be 16.
i bet you she's still in high school
maybe could be could be i'm going to say
18. maybe tyler's right i don't know but
this is this is what's going on first of
all it's important to note this is young
person right they're susceptible they're
vulnerable to this language
she thinks this is funny right it's like
a big joke laughing oh showing the
bracelets all
is it funny to you though like think
about it think about what
her day-to-day life looks like and now
what she has requested that everyone
around her has to function in this
alternate universe right oh she's got a
certain pin on that day she's got a
certain bracelet on that day you have to
acknowledge it you have to abide by
those rules she's stressing this is a
very very confused little girl
that's it
she's confused and this kind of
confusion
about things that are tangibly factual
are being supported by
probably a school
maybe a family it's very very concerning
right because think about it if you can
do this can't you just make anything up
day to day this is not even someone
that's saying
i am
i identify as male
it's beyond that now now it's like every
day is a different day today is upright
do you see it's not this is an unserious
conversation at this point
because now when reality ceases to exist
and facts seems to exist it's just like
free-for-all like
oh today this is this is what it's
become
okay
so
parents i mean i don't know what's going
on here in this house but this is not
this shouldn't be acceptable right
someone has to sit her down and really
figure out what's going on here
and why it's manifesting this way
and i wonder what the other kids feel
they have to just i mean i'm sure she
has friends and it's got to be weird
you got a male friend one day your
female friend what is i don't know maybe
it goes beyond that too
animals i don't know i'm being sincere
because where where is the line right so
this this is this is where we're at and
it's important to show this because it's
not people say oh well it's just men
women no it's not it's this is this is
it now
this level of just
is where we're at with children
children
she's in hello kitty i know that
probably made you think she was i have
hello kitty shirts too though so you
never know you never know she may have
been younger maybe 16 17 could be if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]